hello everyone and welcome back to the
road
2000. uh had a few more uh
technical difficulties tonight but we
are up and running here
and as the title hopefully is telling
you
uh today i am going to take you through
some games
of the immortal wilhelm steinitz
uh the first original world champion
by mymath and he had some really fun
really interesting games
so i wanted to warm up with a little bit
of a miniature against uh
henry edward bird of course bird famous
for his opening
beginning with one f4 and then
we're gonna dive into some rather
complex games
from the world championship match
between johannes zukertortz
and of course wilhelm steinitz so
hopefully you guys
enjoy here we go we have one e4
by steinitz in this game bird replied
with e6
d4 d5 entering the french we have
knight c3 and then bird just simply
captures on
e4 of course bishop b4 is a legal chess
move as well
that has been tried by many many people
knight f6 also a pretty common move here
but do you take c4
by no means bad we have knight take c4
by
steinitz and now we have the move knight
f6
and uh for those of you watching i want
to see if you guys at home
can guess steinan's next move because i
feel like
uh of course uh the more experienced
players in the chat
will be a little bit more familiar with
what's going on here and they'll know
what the best move
is but if you're a little bit new to
this sort of
uh this sort of dynamic between these
two nights you might not
actually realize what the best move is
here for white it might be a little bit
counter-intuitive so go ahead and think
about it
uh what to do with the white pieces here
yeah flash gordon in the chat saying e6
was bird's first mistake you're not
wrong
not wrong uh just take it
from anish giri the french is a
difficult opening to get uh to get a
hold of
so yeah i think a lot of beginners and
probably a lot of experienced chess
players would play the move bishop g5
and bishop g5 is by no means a bad move
it's been played
plenty of times here and this is a
perfectly fine position for
white however
i do believe in this case that white's
quest move is actually to capture this
knight on f6
and that's what was played in the game
and uh oftentimes
we're told when we're sort of learning
chess it's not so good
to make these kinds of trades because
they allow the opponent
to sort of develop naturally right you
spent your entire move taking this
knight
black spent his entire move taking it
back but now what's this
he has one more piece out than white
which does tend to be
sort of an unfortunate thing uh of
course
the exception is here because
we've drawn black's queen out and not
only have we drawn black's queen up but
very importantly it's
gone to a square where it can in fact be
targeted and that's what ends up
winning stein steinitz this game
so of course white should continue
development but he wants to continue
development
with this queen in mind if he doesn't
actually target this queen
say just plays bishop e2 knight f3
castles bishop e3
then in fact knight takes f6 was a
little bit silly to draw the black queen
out
but he wants to develop while keeping in
mind this queen so the move knight f3
comes on the board
knight c6 was black's reply and now of
course
what should white play here
what should white play here
so yeah of course the move to play now
is bishop g5 uh developing
with tempo hitting the queen and uh
this is where steinitz really does start
to take over
uh the entire game uh i think at this
point in time
black is closed to lost already
it is rather rough but uh bird just
moves the queen
out of the way for now with queen to f5
and of course now the the very serious
downside for black is that white is not
done developing
and can bring this bishop out to d3 as
well of course with tempo
and now bird makes sort of his final
mistake
of the game uh he had to play the queen
over to d5 uh or i guess queen a5 check
is also playable but queen d5 makes the
most sense to me
just getting the queen to the
centralized square and sort of out of
harm's way
at least for a few moments instead he
took a rather aggressive approach
with queen to g4 perhaps targeting
the d-pawn perhaps targeting the g-pawn
as well
so if your name is wilhelm steinitz
how are you going to respond to queen g4
white to move and win the game uh manny
says was 96 a mistake what's the modern
reply to knight f3
so yeah knight c6 was a pretty serious
mistake uh these days
this threat of bishop g5 is so severe
that players often just play the move
uh h6 to stop bishop g5 directly
they often just play h6 to stop bishop
g5
altogether
that's how powerful it is
so chat room the queen's on g4 what
to do what can be done uh
all right i'm not gonna wait around for
the delay i'm sure some people
already have the answer by the time they
hear me say it of course
the move is h3 and this is a
really interesting tactic it's one that
you'll see most often happen
on the queen side right the queen comes
out to p6 hits b2
and oftentimes the way to trap this
queen
is to actually play the move a3
uh but on that side of the board uh let
me just
pull up a random position here
if i'm talented enough of course this is
all going to be nonsense
a3 takes okay off
one more move a3 takes
oftentimes when the queen captures on b2
the point is the a
pawn takes away the final retreating
square for the queen and then the move
knight a4
traps the queen the rook defends the
pawn very cleanly the queen defends the
rook
and the queen is just totally stuck
everybody's seen this this tactic
a billion times however what's the trick
here
well after queen takes g2 which was
played of course knight h4 is not going
to get the job done here for multiple
reasons number one
the g5 bishop would hang and number two
the rook on h1 would hang as well
so what was steinitz's points what
happens after h3
so yes of course we don't play the
natural looking rook g1
which allows the queen to escape with
queen takes h3
uh but instead he plays the move rook
to h2 instead which does keep control
of everything and trap this queen uh
entirely
uh and that of course was just the end
of the game uh bird played a few more
moves
takes h2 takes h2 takes on d4 and then
the last move of the game how did
steinitz uh convince his opponent to
resign
how does steinitz convince his opponent
to resign after knight to d4
winning a queen wasn't enough bird is
not convinced he should resign yet
you have to do better
have to do better here and so of course
the last move
of the game is bam bishop b5
check as you guys are saying and the
point now
is that queen to d8 is going to be
a rather sad checkmate for bird
definitely not a good day for
the namesake of 1f4 uh here today so
hopefully you guys enjoyed
that little uh miniature there once
again
uh black's mistake uh first of all
knight f6
really isn't so common these days
because knight takes f6 is just a good
move
and then even after knight f6 knight f3
black pretty much exclusively plays the
move h6 here just you have to stop this
bishop g5 idea
it's not good for black to have this
queen be so vulnerable
on the f6 square um all right
with that let's jump into the main
uh the main event here today we have
zukertortz against
steinitz and
like a fool i didn't label which round
was which but this is
some round from their world championship
match
and this one starts with the one move
one d4
one d5 c4 e6
knight c3 knight f6 so of course we have
the classic
queen's gambit declined and all three of
our games from the world championship
that we're looking at tonight are in
fact going to be in this opening line
and we are going to see zukertort take
three different approaches
and we're going to see all three of them
sort of blow up in his face
unfortunately for him uh in the game the
move bishop g5 is played
of course white can also go for the
exchange uh with c takes d5
and can also just play the the calmer
knight to f3
uh bishop g5 played in this game though
is one of the main variations
bishop e7 is very very natural for black
unpinning the knight keeping good
control of the d5 pawn
and now after knight f3 uh developing
normally
we see the move castles
and we are in very very main line theory
and now what made me want to go over
this game first
is white's next move here so of course
you know white has plenty of options e3
you know developing this way developing
this way
still not too late to take on d5 if
nearly once you can even play a nothing
move like
a3 if you really want in this position
although you should
rather quickly defend the c4 pawn so i i
think e3 is the best move
but really any of those moves are fine
instead
white takes a very very ambitious
approach here white plays this move c5
and this is sort of something that i
love to do when i was
an up and coming youngster climbing my
way up through that raiding ladder
around you know 14 1500 i was like man
this c5 stuff that's where it's at
that's how you win
games with the white pieces i just play
c5
and then my opponents have no idea what
to do they have no space
and they they just get sort of
annihilated
unfortunately steinitz is was
a bit better than my opponents were when
i was sort of getting away with c5
and so he knows what to do against this
but i felt like it was really important
to show this game
because this idea can be really really
uncomfortable
for black if black doesn't sort of
strike back immediately
just as an example of sort of the
nightmare scenarios you could run into
if something like c6 which is not a bad
move
let's say let's say
knight e5 for example knight
to d7 and
something like f4 already right you can
start to imagine how things could
go could go wrong let's say something
like rookie 8 just a nothing move
b4 a6 a3
all of a sudden it's very clear i just
played lego k7
it's very clear none of black's pieces
are going to be able to do anything you
know someday black might
capture on e5 and try to play knight e4
but this is is really not going to be
enough compensation for black here just
all of these pieces
sort of stuck behind their own pawns and
this is sort of the idea
for uh for white in a lot of these cases
maybe not so much allowing takes on e5
but sort of just taking a ton of space
on the queen side
and completely locking down the opponent
so what is the proper way
to respond to c5 well what do you guys
think in the chat room
uh what are some options for black to
try
and uh fight back against pawn to c5
so you guys already have the two main
ideas
the the two main ideas here so of course
uh idea number one
is the idea that was played in this game
and it is very often just the
the best way of responding to uh to this
c5 idea
and it's to fight back with the move b6
and just immediately start
fighting for these squares on the queen
side
and it does turn out that this does tend
to be a little bit more advantageous
uh to black depending on how things go
because white is just a bit too
overextended over here
on the queen side and i believe we're
actually going to see
black employ a very important second
idea
a few moves later in the game so b6 is a
good start
b6 is a great way to start attacking the
pawn chain
at its head is what this is sort of
called you
challenge the over extended c5 pawn and
of course white is not going to be
interested in capturing
opening up the a file allowing black to
capture towards the center
and gain good control over the c5 square
so instead white is pretty much forced
into
playing the move b4 to just support this
pawn even further
and now i want to ask you guys with
black here what do you do
what do you do some people said they
wanted to push with a5 rather
immediately
is that what you want to do do you want
to take on c5
do you want to play c6 do you want to do
something else
what do you think what do you think
so
it does actually turn out that i believe
the best idea here for black
is to actually just play this move a5 uh
just directly
and this is what a lot of people in the
chat were saying and from what i've seen
there's just really no reason to leave
this pawn back on a7
you would want white to bring this pawn
out to a3 and then you can take
sort of at your leisure you don't
necessarily want to take right away
oftentimes you shouldn't
but it's good to have sort of this pawn
here and then
after this a move like knight e4 is is
probably just going to be very strong
for black for example trades might occur
i think we can even take on c3 here uh
maybe we should just take here though
takes takes knight e5 for example and
we can fracture white's pawns we have
sort of this tension
that white can never release and we have
very active pieces
with this bishop on b7 and we'll develop
the night outs
rather shortly with knight d7 and black
is just significantly better here
in the game steinitz took a more direct
approach and just immediately captured
on c5
and while steinis did go on to win this
game i do think this is
a little bit of a misstep by black this
is one of those cases where
white doesn't really ever have any
options uh to relieve the tension
himself
right you play the move a5 a3 even if
you play a slow move like c6
uh white is like i said never really
going to be capturing either of these
pawns
so because of that you can sort of wait
as long as you like
in before capturing on either of these
pawns
and white's never going to really be
able to do anything about it
with all that in mind though after takes
we do actually see
zukertort take back with the d-pawn
now perhaps taking back with the b-pawn
would be a little bit better in light of
black's next move after d takes c5
of course uh steinitz plays the very uh
familiar move a5 now
uh and a5 is is just quite strong
because white committed to taking this
with the d
pawn and now the c pawn is going to be
very very weak if the b
pawn should ever fall uh and now
we see white play the move a3
uh so black to move here black to move
you
you can tell based on opening principles
alone
that white has sort of been violating
some of them
he's making a ton of reactive pawn moves
trying to gain a ton of space early
early on and he has neglected to develop
his bishop and castle his king so of
course
what should you start looking for when
your opponent has neglected to develop
and castle uh well you should start
looking for ways
to open things up and get at the white
king
so what's the best way to do that here
what's the best way
to open things up and start pushing
towards that king
knight c6 has been suggested
knight e4 has been suggested
we'll talk about those in a in a little
bit
so no one has suggested uh the winning
move just yet believe it or not
working with a little bit more delay
than normal tonight
so forgive me if i'm slow on the
responses here
yeah no one has quite the right idea you
guys are looking for you know solid
positional moves
but black actually has some some nice
tactics at his disposal
not necessarily tactics to win material
directly
but uh tactics that allow him to play
moves
he maybe otherwise couldn't
so there are plenty of fine developing
moves that you can play
but now i actually do see the the
correct move in the chat here
uh black can actually just play this
move d4
very very directly you don't need to
prepare it with knight c6 you don't need
to prepare it with
with anything else you can just play the
move d4
now of course if knight takes d4 what is
this tactic that i'm talking about
well it's this tension that black has on
the queen side as i said
black can always wait to take on b4
until it's under very favorable
circumstances
and after knight takes d4 those
circumstances have finally arrived
a takes b4 and capturing back is not
possible
due to the weakness on d4 of this knight
and of course this is going to be very
winning for black if he can take a3
as all of white's once glorious queen
side pawns start to
collapse now if you do play a move like
knight c6 you do have to be a little bit
careful i think because
b5 could sort of ruin your day
i think you can still get away with
playing knight a7 here
and too many of black's pawns are are
hanging
for comfort but you have to be very very
careful
because stuff like c6 can really start
to come
and uh yeah if you let white play the
move a4
then all of a sudden i think black is in
pretty serious trouble here so you do
have to be a bit cautious
moves like h6 are perfectly fine as well
and knight e4
definitely isn't a bad move but it's not
sort of that that
uh winning attack on the king that i was
looking for because of course here
uh simply trading uh the queens is going
to be possible for um
uh four white here and you can play
something like
knight knight e5 i think you do win the
b
pawn here uh which should be enough to
win the game but you're not really
checkmating the white king which is what
we're looking for
so the move d4 is a great winning move
to start
uh forcing back the white pieces
and to start getting closer and closer
to attacking this uncastled king
now zukertort chose the move bishop
takes f6 here
and steinitz makes a pretty interesting
decision bishop takes f6 was fine
but he wanted to keep pressure up on the
c5 pawn i think and he actually
recaptures
with the g pawn which is perfectly fine
here for black of course
the same issue sort of persists if you
try to take this pawn you take with the
queen
black can take first and then take a
take on b4 don't know if i mentioned
uh and so now white plays the move
knight to a4
uh and now the move that i was talking
about a long time ago does finally come
on the board
black just plays the move e5 and what we
have here is a classic
case of black taking over the center
because white started pushing on the
wing
this is sort of one of the uh all-time
great examples
of countering an attack on the flank
with an attack in the center
and steinitz did it very very well in
the opening
and we'll see now that he does manage to
convert it into the full point
with even more sort of astounding
accuracy
and e5 a long time ago uh
way back here when we were discussing
options for black uh e5 is sort of the
secondary idea that black has at his
disposal to fight against this move c5
why is that well b6 attacks the pawn at
the head of the pawn chain
but as i think manny was mentioning in
the chat you can try something like
knight c6
and if i give a move or two to black
here
let's say bishop d3 something like e
well okay i
can't hang this guy so maybe another
move for black
something like e5 is going to be good
for black countering an attack on the
flank
with an attack in the center white is
really unable to capture
well i guess white can capture but now
the point is
this pawn is going to be very very weak
without the d4
pawn to support it so that was another
another idea that i just wanted to
mention
of course though b6 in this case is
quite good for black
so we have takes takes and now e5 uh
white sort of desperately goes for
goes for b5 here trying to
make his queen side pawns at least
useful and black just takes this
opportunity
to develop the bishop out to e6 and like
i said
it's sort of just completely crushing uh
the move
g3 comes on the board white does also
now
finally tried to develop his king's side
and
c6 comes by black just totally
neutralizing all of the threats on the
queen side of the board
uh white would love to play the move ace
or would love to play the move b6
but i think here uh what do i think here
i think knight a6
is going to be plenty to sort of recoup
this pawn
uh if you play the move rook c1
queen d5 and it is getting very very
difficult
to uh to keep up with the threats to
this pawn if queen c2
queen b3 even and all of the white
pieces
are starting to lose their grip on the
on the pawn for example bishop g2 we can
take here
play bishop b3 and things are busted
for white so instead of b6 zuker tries
to move b takes c6
and we get knight takes c6 in response
bishop g2 by zukatort is very very
natural and now steinitz plays the move
rook b8
uh just stepping off of this uh long
open diagonal
to follow it up we see white play the
move uh queen
to c1 uh of course
rook b8 also sorry was coming with the
threat of bishop b3
so that's why we see queen c1 by white
stepping out of this threat
uh which would have won a knight so now
with black you know the
the moment of truth is here you've
gotten all your pieces out and your
opponent
still is uh uncastled in the center of
the board
so how do you make use of your central
pawns here
what can you do to actually win the game
um
so yeah manny has the uh the right idea
here
you just push this move uh d3 and
white is sort of uh sort of busted
sort of just busted if white tries to
take on d3
then i think black would simply
recapture on d3
and now sort of no matter what happens
uh
if queen d1 for example you're running
back into this
fork if something like queen b will
queen b1 can't be played there's really
no way to contest this queen bishop f1
hangs a knight
queen d1 like i said also hangs in
knight and this queen is just
uncontested if you play rook a2 you you
can't that square is defended and rugby
one hangs
if you play knight d2 for example knight
d4 is going to come
and really white is just left without a
way
to uh to get back into this game
if queen c3 this actually also hangs a
knight there's really no way to contest
this queen so d3
is the killer move zukertort chooses the
move e3 instead to try to keep
everything locked down
and now the simple choice of e4 by
steinitz and this space is a bit
too cramped for uh for white knight d2
comes on the board
and now f5 just defending the center
white finally gets kingside castles
kingside castled
but notably he didn't get to do so for
free right while we didn't succeed
in checkmating this king in the center
of the board it did allow us to get this
pawn all the way to d3
and white was unable to trade it off for
the e pawn
thanks to the weakness of that king so
this is the big benefit
that uh that black got out of pushing
this pawn
so far up the board black plays uh
a pretty interesting move here rook to
e8 which on the surface doesn't make a
ton of sense right it's just a random
merc move
but you might see in a few turns that
black had
a a pretty killer idea with it in mind
and now
uh white plays the move f3 and this sort
of had to be done
right white has to challenge these
central pawns for black
or else he's just gonna lose the game
and now finally you guys
the moment has come black to move and
win the chess game just very
definitively
win the chess game here
what you guys gots what you guys got
your opponent played f3 if you don't
find this move your center might start
to collapse
might start to collapse
okay so um i'm not gonna lie to you guys
here there
is more than one winning move i think in
this position
uh black is pretty crushing but this one
once you find it there's really no need
to look for for other moves and yeah you
guys have it here
aryan and manny uh all with the correct
answer
uh knight to d4 is the crushing idea
and what's the point well the point is
this e3 pawn is
all that's stopping black from getting
everything to glory
right getting all these pawns to glory
you might be thinking
ah yeah knight d4 it's very clever if he
takes i can take back and pick up the
knight on a4
if that's what you were thinking
congratulations on fighting the fun
move knight d4 we're not interested in
taking this knight though this knight is
is worthless to us we're interested in
queening these pawns
uh of course black or sorry white does
sort of have to capture here if he tries
something like
uh king to h1 stepping out of the fork
i think i mean i think everything wins
but if i had to put a move on the board
i would say 92 is pretty good
yeah let's say 92 queen e1
and now we can even just take here and
follow up with bishop g5 and our knight
in the middle of the board
or sorry in the middle of the white camp
is going to be sort of devastating
we can also put the knight on c2 if we
want and this is also quite good
you can also put the knight on b through
if we want it's also quite good just put
the knight anywhere
and you sort of win the game white was
up to the task though and did try
capturing on d4
of course takes back with check uh king
h1
and now like i said we're not really
interested in taking this knight on a4
when white could start to capture our
stuff back in the center
but rather the move e3 is sort of just
devastating here
uh knight c3 was white's attempt to try
to get back into the game
and now bishop f6 is a nice follow-up
all of the black pieces working together
very very well
and you can see that this rook on e8 is
now well placed with the freedom of
movement
that the e pawn has uh knight
uh d to b1 was played the simple move d2
queen c2 bishop b3 now
just getting the queen out of there the
f5 pawn means nothing
uh queen takes f5 and now black goes
ahead and queens his
first pawn we see takes takes knight c3
e2 rook a takes d1
and after queen takes c3 zukertort
resigned the game
with both of his rooks unfortunately
hanging
in the position and uh yeah like i said
i wanted to go over this game
because of white's choice in this
opening to play the move c5
it's something that was always very
attractive to me as i was
learning chess more and more at the club
level
and once you see this game i i think
it's hard to convince yourself to play
the move c5 with white ever again
it's just such a disaster what happened
to zugertort in this world championship
uh in this world championship game so
once again let's take a quick look at
all of the highlights here
so white chooses this move c5 black
immediately strikes back with b6 not
taking a slower approach which is good
b4 and takes on c5 isn't totally
necessary but it's fine for black
and now a5 is good for black once again
white needed to capture back with the b
pawn when once again
black can start looking for ideas of
pushing the move e5
and now a5 is good d4 taking advantage
of the opponent's king position
and the tactics available to black on
the queen side
uh knight over to a4 now e5
and finally we see this move
uh rook b8 making a threat and d3
to take advantage of the opponent's king
position
for one more move and of course
the nice breakthrough knight d4
and uh i want to give you guys a little
bit of a spoiler here if you think
knight d4 looks like a really really
cool move
you're definitely going to want to stick
around for the end game class right
after this
when i'm going to be showing you guys a
ton of tactics
that all revolve around this theme of
breaking through
in end games of getting blockers out
of the way so that you can start to
clean pawns so knight d4
this idea showing up not in an end game
in this case but in a middle game
uh allowing steinitz to just sort of
destroy
zuckertory in this game uh with all that
in mind let's
move along
could i point out the important
difference of the bishop f4 line where
white also plays c4
c5 so yeah um
there's a few differences there let's
take a look
let's see if i can actually even
remember it here uh let's say bishop f4
e3 castles uh
knight f3 i want to say
bd7 c5 right okay so
the the differences here is first of all
black has already committed this knight
to d7
so if black if black plays the move b6
now all of a sudden c6 is a very
legitimate option that wasn't before
also he's gonna have to worry about this
move to follow so black has to take a
little bit of extra time to play the
move c6
after bishop d3 b6 b4
now of course we're always taking this
guy with the with the b
pawn and here uh
the the key difference is white is
pretty much totally developed
right white is totally developed and 94
tactics which were sometimes strong
in the game that we looked at with the
bishop on g5 always being attacked
they're really not going to work quite
as well with white well
well prepared to deface it that being
said this line isn't bad for black at
all either
he does get the bishop out through
through a6
another key point that i want to mention
of course is on f4
white is keeping good control over the
e5 square which as i said is the other
important break for black in the
position
whereas with on the bishop on g5 the e5
ideas
really do gain quite a bit in strength
so basically this is just a much much
better version
of the same for white here now of course
though
this line is playable whereas the other
line
is sort of just awful for uh for white
good question though good question
so yeah um funny stuff in the chat
it can also be played in the pan off so
yes that's true it can be played in the
pan off
you guys are really asking a lot of my
opening theory uh
knowledge here in the panov it's a bit
different without the e pawn
uh once again it's
just subtle differences and i'm trying
to remember
the exact pawn structure it's it's just
a different pawn structure right
it's just a slightly different pawn
structure if i can sort of navigate my
way
out to the position let's say e6
c5 or something yeah uh
it's it's just a different structure
here of course the c pawn is actually
passed there's no counter c
pawn for black black is already
committed to the move e6 so he's not
playing e5 in one tempo
and yeah you're gonna find this idea of
c5 arrive in some positions
but generally black is always going to
be okay if you can
get this counter play in time with b6
and a5 and the move e5 but yeah
it is playable in some positions i don't
mean to say that it's always always
always a bad move
uh just that it it is more the exception
that c5 is a good move than
than the rule generally c5 just allows
black
some quick counter play but you will
find it in some opening lines alright
with all that in mind let's go ahead and
move on here
to another game so this of course is
still zooker towards steinitz and in
this game
we'll see zugertort has sort of reformed
his ways here
actually no this is the game i want to
go over last so
we'll go for uh go for this one instead
we have the same opening though and
here actually rather than even get the
chance to play the move c5 which
i kind of doubt zootor would want to do
we instead see the move d takes c4
by black which is just a different uh
different line it's still totally fine
uh e3 now for whites and black
immediately strikes back
in the center with the move c5 uh and
this is
more or less an attempt for black to
equalize straight out of the opening
whenever you see black do this
uh what do i mean by that well i mean
that
generally in a lot of positions white is
going to be the one ending up
with a little bit of extra space uh in
the center
thanks to his opening play moving two
pawns to the fourth rank directly
and black is gonna have to struggle to
catch up play c6 maybe play c5 later
maybe play e5 later maybe we just have
an exchange on d5
but when black takes on c4 like this and
plays c5
black is just saying yeah all right i'm
trading my d and c
pawns for your dnc pawns and then you'll
have no reason to be better
because he won't have any extra space in
the game though we see bishop takes c4
and now after c takes d4 e takes d4
we have the dreaded iqp
so let's see uh how this iqp turns out
here
for zukertor steinitz um
and i do want to briefly mention that if
you're ever looking
to see
at a reasonably high level these opening
ideas
like the iqp like white playing in an
early c5
uh these other early ideas that don't
see play at the top level anymore
if you want to see them played and sort
of battled out in high level games
this world championship match is
definitely the one for you because back
then
they had no idea if this was good or bad
you know they didn't have computers they
didn't have you know
centuries of of work to go off of and so
they they sort of just played things
and and worked it out over the board and
so we'll see now
uh what black's play was like against
the iqp here uh bishop e7 of course is
very natural just getting developed
uh sort of in advance breaking any pins
here keeping everything solid
we see castles and castles
uh white plays the move queen e2 which
looks a little bit strange at first
glance
but uh it has some pretty dangerous
attacking ideas
with some chances to sacrifice on e6
if black gets a little bit careless and
maybe brings the bishop out this way
it also allows the rook to step to d1 to
support the d-pawn from behind
and on a very very good day you might
see uh
might see a checkmate occur knight b
to d7 was steinitz's choice so why do
you think steinitz chose the move
knight d knight b to d7 over the move
knight c6
why knight b to d7 here
so yeah iqp of course standing for the
isolated
queen's pawn the pawn on the queen's
starting file
when it is isolated iqp
so why not bd7 well of course it is all
about the d5 square
right so standards plays the move knight
b to d7
uh even though it looks a little bit
more awkward than knight c6 which would
pressure
the d-pawn because he simply wants to go
knight b6
and knight d5 it's it's as simple as
that it's not some
you know deep complex strategy it's just
against the iqp
it's very very important to control the
square in front of the pawn
a lot of times much more so than trying
to pressure the pawn directly you just
want to make sure
that pawn can't advance and sort of ruin
your day
that being said knight c6 isn't
necessarily a bad move at all
why is that well because unless white
plays the move a3
which he can't hear because the pawn is
hanging so rook d1
he can go with the same idea of playing
knight b4 and once again
you are going to see the knight land on
the d5 square
but knight b to d7 oftentimes is
a more natural way of getting there
because knight c6 doesn't always come
with tempo right sometimes white does
have time to play a3 here
and if so then this knight might not be
the happiest on c6 it might have to try
to come back to e7
to get to d5 and like i said just might
not always be the happiest so knight b
to d7
is sort of a surefire way of getting to
d5
bishop b3 was played in the game
actually anticipating black's next move
of knight b6
and now bishop f4 black simply takes
control
of the d5 square and plants a knight on
that square with a little controversy
of course the knight on d5 is pressuring
the bishop on
f4 also of course when you do have the
isolated queens pawn yourself you want
to avoid
trading a ton of minor pieces because
they're
they're sort of the ammunition that you
need to launch
some kind of an attack right you want to
put this knight on e5
using your extra space you want to put
some pressure on the h7 pawn using this
bishop
and with this knight sometimes you can
even jump into e4
to start removing some defenders so
white wanting to avoid minor piece
trades plays the move bishop g3
which is perfectly natural now black
plays a pretty interesting move here
he plays the move queen a5 and i i kind
of like this move
uh oftentimes in these kinds of openings
for black the queen just
ends up sort of in the way right this
bishop's taking away the c7 square the
d6 square
the c file is open so c7 isn't that
comfortable anyways
and it makes a lot of sense to get the
queen out of the way
along with uh along with pressuring this
knight on c3
uh the rook comes a to c1 and now
steinitz manages to develop his bishop
with the move bishop d7 and this might
be an idea a lot of you
aren't as familiar with these days i
think
steinitz was sort of known for
developing his bishop in this manner
quite a bit nowadays i think a lot more
common
top players really really strive to get
the bishop out along this diagonal
but we'll see that there is actually
definite benefits to to not getting it
out along this diagonal
and playing bishop d7 so many of you
probably think well
why is this bishop going to d7 well of
course it's heading for
c6 and you would actually be a bit wrong
there
so steinitz's idea in this case
was that white has made a weakness by
isolating this pawn on d4
so all the pressure's on white white has
to make something happen here
and if white doesn't make something
happen then he's just gonna be saddled
with this weakness
in the long run so with all that in mind
after knight e5 which is natural
rook to d8 of course once again white
isn't so interested
in this minor peace trade we saw the
move queen f3
and now the bishop doesn't step to c6
but rather steps back to e8
and what we see now is a very you know
sort of conservative approach from black
most of his pieces sitting on the first
three ranks here
but a very solid approach and all of his
pieces are working together
very harmoniously he has good control
over d5
with uh his rook his queen and his
knights
he has good control over the weak f7
square by this bishop
on e8s and white is sort of left uh
feeling a bit helpless uh feeling like
there isn't too much to be done here
and that turns out to be exactly the
case so this bishop d7 to e8 maneuver is
definitely not ridiculous
and so i think this is a good one to uh
to keep in mind here
not always getting the bishop out to the
most active square but bishops
serving a good defensive role can be
good pieces as well
rook f2e1 was played in the game and now
rook a to c8
uh here zukertor really did feel the
need
to try and drum something up and so he
plays the move bishop h4
uh bishop h4 of course now pressuring
this knight on f6
so indirectly pressuring this knight on
d5
and uh now i want to ask you guys a
question right
so the move knight takes c3 is
definitely playable here
for black so let's say if you take on c3
and your opponent takes back with the b
pawn are you guys happy about that
change in structure
are you happy to draw white's pawn
to the c3 square or
not and why
and why
so nobody's happy about this changing
structure
everybody hates it that's what the chat
room seems to uh
have decided on and uh
in general uh i will say that it is very
very tempting
to try and get you know this perfect
scenario where the iqp remains
isolated for the rest of eternity and
you just trade off all the pieces and
then you're in some great end game and
you just win
the isolated queen pawn right
unfortunately the reality of that
is a little bit messier and i will say
that at least myself personally in most
of my games where i'm playing against
the iqp
at one point or another i do end up
taking this knight
on c3 and even though after b takes c3
uh white is supporting the d4 pawn a bit
more solidly
in the long run white is still going to
have a lot of weaknesses
to contend with uh for example now c3
is a definite weakness and we'll see a
little bit later in the game white
pushes this pawn to c4
but then he always has to keep track of
not one
but but both pawns the obvious downside
to this is with this pawn coming to c4
white sort of has twice as many threats
threatening the step to d5
with a little more support and also
threatening to step to uh to c5 as well
so definitely there are upsides and
downsides to this
uh the major upside and why it was
played in the game is it does
for the moment alleviate the pressure on
d5 right we took off this knight on c3
which was very uncomfortably uh applying
this pressure to the d5 square
black now retreats this queen all the
way back to c7
thanks to the c file being closed and
thanks to this bishop no longer
occupying the g3 square
notably also he is unpinning his knight
with this move
queen d3 was the next move in the game
trying to support both pawns from behind
with the queen
and once again we see the move knight d5
as i said before black is always always
always
looking for opportunities to trade off
some minor pieces
against uh both the iqp and now what's
called sort of the hanging
pawn structure with these two pawns
isolated from the rest of the group
but still connected and so we do see
bishop take c
e7 queen takes c7 and then white
actually captures
on the d5 square and i do think that
this
is a little bit of a positional mistake
uh white could try to play the move c4
and while this knight does get active
stepping to b4 and back to c6
i think it is a bit better for white in
this case to follow those principles
and understand that keeping minor pieces
on is going to be
the the way to go here for him instead
though we did see bishop takes and now
after rook takes
c4 and rook d to d8s
unfortunately for white well he does
have now these very very
active pawns uh he's traded off a bit to
a few too many pieces
in order to attain this position and i
do think i would actually rather be
black in this specific scenario
objectively i think the evaluation is
still probably really close to equal
but practically i do think it is black
here
who uh has a little bit less pressure on
them whenever you get these structures
with white
you're always under a lot of pressure to
make something happen to push d5 to get
the breakthrough
and a lot of the time it's it's just not
going to be there for
not going to be there for you uh white
plays the move rook to e3
and black very naturally just attacks
the d4 pawn
again now we see the move rook to d1
and all of a sudden this bishop which is
looking so so silly
all game long is starting to get a
little bit of scope
after the move f6 right this net on e5
is was not going to stay there forever
and i think this move f6
is what definitively allows me to say
that bishop takes d5
was a mistake once these minor pieces
start disappearing from the board
black has all this freedom to start
taking back some squares
with weakening moves like f6 because
there just simply aren't the pieces on
the board
for white to take advantage
white plays a nice little inner meso
here of rook h3
with the threat of checkmates
black responds rather simply with the
move h6
knight g6 might look tempting by the way
but it doesn't actually achieve a whole
lot so white drops the knight back to g4
instead
we see queen f4 and now knight e3
and finally finally finally we have all
of black's pieces
serving a nice attacking role besides
the bishop
but we can fix that with black's next
move bishop a4
white plays another enemazo of rook f3
queen back to d6
rook d2 is now forced to keep control
over the d4
pawn and now the simple move bishop c6
gets played
rook g3 and now another fun move by
black here
f5 is the move to take some more central
space allowing for this bishop to come
out to e4
rook g6 makes a threat to the f5 pawn
but now bishop e4
queen b3 king h7 and these pieces uh
do start to get a little bit evicted
here
and finally now i believe white
is uh just actually busted sorry king h7
is defending this trick i thought
white's losing move like came next
but it does turn out that white's losing
move is in fact going to be this move
rook g6
um already here though i would say once
again
i would definitely prefer black with all
this pressure
to the white pawns in the center but
yeah rook g6 does turn out to be the
losing move thanks to bishop e4
and king h7 when this work is totally
trapped
white tried this move c5 but tactically
this
doesn't quite turn out to work so black
to move
and win in this position uh give me a
little bit of a sequence here try
not to just uh give me the first move
the first move is not so difficult to
find
but finding a little bit of a sequence
is slightly more interesting
did sort win any games in this match uh
yes he did i don't actually remember the
final score
but uh zukator did win a win a few games
off of steinis
so yeah manny actually saw the tactic uh
coming in advance here uh
with this pin on the c file yes rook
takes c5
is the the playable move here of course
though
the the line doesn't end there right
white has this move rook takes e6
and now the move rook c1 check comes on
the board
and white is going to be a little bit uh
hard-pressed to find
a suitable reply to this he tried to
move knight d1
but now after queen f4 all of black's
pieces
are are coming into the game and uh and
yeah white is
just just busted queen b2 rook b1
forces the queen away queen c3
and now once again can you guys find
uh well i guess technically the second
to last move of the game here
for black rook c5 was a nice start
but this is the beautiful finish
um
the beautiful finish here chat room what
do you see what do you not see
yeah go ahead and ask me whatever you
want to ask sharma
the killer move is queen g4 bishop takes
g2
you guys aren't there just yet guys
aren't there just yet i think those
moves probably win
yeah all the moves probably win queen g4
maybe there's f3 i don't know it looks a
bit awkward
but uh yeah chess king has the answer
here
the beautiful move is rook c8 and this
is the move
that puts zukertort out of the game of
course this rook cannot be captured
because of queen takes d2 with checkmate
to follow
if you try something like queen e3 i
think now the simplest is to go rook
c to c1 anyways queen takes f4
gets met with checkmate and there's
simply no way to defend this knight
in the actual game rook takes e4 was
played queen takes c4 was played
and zukertort resigned here now of
course
this cannot be captured due to the
threat of checkmates
and that is just about going to do it
for us here
on the road to 2000. uh does anybody
have any questions
about this game before we call it quits
and move on to the end game class
any questions for me here
so yeah not queen g4 rather but rook c8
bringing the final piece into the attack
is
the tactic to end this game
yeah manny saw this back rank mate
coming about 20 moves in advance
well done well done
all right yeah just waiting for the
delay to catch up here it looks like we
don't have too many questions
so i am going to call it quits here for
the road to 2000
be sure to stick around we do have the
end game class
uh coming up right next and as i
mentioned earlier in the lecture it's
gonna be a pretty fun one tonight
i have a ton of end game tactics for you
guys which isn't something that we do
every week
but i think it's going to be a lot of
fun going to be a lot of fun
what is a good book for 2 200 players uh
you you tell me
um i'm around 2200 and these days
normally the books i'm reading tend to
be opening books that's what i find to
be the most useful
but
how can i improve as an 1800 player
these questions are too general i meant
about the chess game i meant about the
chess game
yeah general improvement uh obviously
it's it's different for everybody but
as always just keep playing chess keep
doing what you're enjoying
and uh the rating points will come in
the long run that's always been my
philosophy
um all right i am gonna call it there
thank you guys so much for joining me
here on the road 2000
of course be sure to join me right after
this
for the end game class uh